Justine - Hey guys, it's Justine
and today we are checking
out the brand new Mac Mini.
I have been a Mac Mini fan
since the very first Mac Mini.
I actually won my first Mac
Mini on a contest on MySpace.
This was super shady.
The fact that I actually
got a Mac Mini in the mail
and not murdered is shocking to me.
I think this was right
when I was in college
and I didn't really have a job so
I really didn't have any
money, didn't have a computer,
I didn't really have much of anything
except I guess my dignity, but.
(beep)
So let's un-box this.
It has many use cases
and I feel like for me,
I may have a different
use case than many people
because I do edit pretty much
everything on my iMac Pro,
and that thing is so fast
that for me to realistically
use one of these
to sort of offload some
compressing from compressor,
probably isn't that realistic.
Because my iMac Pro, I
can still compress videos
and edit at the same time
and usually there's no lag.
So that may not be a use case
but I do plan on editing
this entire video,
that you're watching
right now on the Mac Mini
so I'll give you some updates
as this video progresses.
(plastic crinkling)
This now has an all space gray finish.
It's made of a 100% recyclable aluminum,
which is pretty incredible
because there is so many
processes that they said
they have to go through to
sort of make this aluminum
that is recycled look
as perfect as it does.
So that's decreasing the carbon
footprint of these products
by a pretty significant amount.
Oh, wow, it's just right there.
I was not ready for that.
Look at you.
They also have a larger air vent,
so that will help with increased airflow.
It smells really good.
It smells like Cupertino,
like if you're ever in Cupertino,
just take a whiff of that fresh air
and this is what it smells like.
Look at all of these ports!
This is definitely something
that I'm excited about,
especially using my MacBook so often
and having to use a dongle
just to be able to actually use my laptop.
Okay, let's see what else we have in here.
Little tiny papers.
Do I not have any stickers?
But you always give us stickers!
Here they are.
Oh, wow, I was in quite the panic.
Found.
Power cable.
Have you seen one of these before?
So here's the power button,
here's the port for the power,
ethernets, four Thunderbolt 3 USB-C ports,
HDMI and two USB-3s, and a headphone jack.
So some of the highlights
in the new Mac Mini
is it's it starts out at four cores
but you can upgrade to six.
60% faster graphics than
the previous version.
You can max it out to 64 gigs of RAM.
They've also switched
all of the new Mac Minis
to solid-state drives,
so this will also go up to two terabytes.
(upbeat techno music)
Now that everything's all set up,
I have Final Cut installed.
What I'm going to do is
I'm going to start editing
this video that you guys
are watching right now.
I know I'm always fascinated by looking
at people's Final Cut timelines.
So as I'm editing I'll also show you
my Final Cut timeline
of the finished piece,
so you guys can check it out.
I'm also curious, do any
of you guys edit Final Cut?
What do you edit on?
I would love to know.
Leave them in the comments below.
Oh, wow, this is actually,
so this was my MacBook Air video.
(upbeat techno music)
As you can see, here's
me editing the video
that you're currently watching.
This is some weird inception.
One of things that I want to try out is
connecting the Mac Mini to my iMac Pro,
so if I'm editing or doing something
I can offload rendering to my Mac Mini,
so I can continue to do
things on my iMac Pro,
and I'm excited to test that out,
although it's crazy because
my iMac Pro is so fast
that a lot of times I will
be compressing something
and editing at the same time
and it really doesn't
hinder the performance.
So that's cool, it's an option.
During the Keynote they
had a stack of them
and it looked so awesome.
It did actually look like a spaceship.
This new space gray color is amazing.
So let's watch something.
I'm actually borrowing Jenna's 4K monitor.
Let's watch a really great video
from this one channel that I love so much.
They were screaming out of their cars.
- Girl, I said I will fight you right now.
(laughing)
- I will see you guys in the next video.
Let me know in the comments below
what you guys think of the Mac Mini.
I would love to hear
some of your use cases.
Do you know anyone who has a Mac Mini?
Do you have a Mac Mini?
For me personally, this may
not be the specific use case
that I would need as a
solution for my editing needs
because I do have an iMac Pro.
I have a MacBook Pro
that I edit when I travel
but this could maybe just
be my new kitchen machine.
I think if Jenna let's me
keep her monitor, we can--
- [Jenna] That's my gaming monitor.
- It is your gaming monitor.
This thing is really nice.
I can't believe it.
I've never gamed on this before.
It's nice.
- [Jenna] It's mine.
- I have the BenQ ones.
I should look into this LG one.
Anyway, I'm getting sidetracked.
Thanks for watching, I'll see
you guys in my next video.
If you guys enjoyed this
video give it a thumbs up
and don't forget to subscribe.
I have a really fun iPad video
coming out for you very, very shortly,
as soon as I get done
shooting and editing it.
So look for that soon.
I will see you guys later
and don't forget about the
MacBook Air or iPad Pro giveaway.
There's more information about that video
in my MacBook Air video.
I'll see you guys later.
Bye bye!
(slow techno music)